I saw the two times the Academy honored
me with the Oscar with the happiest and
proudest and most emotional moments an
actor could have now I know I was wrong
because tonight I'm filled with the same
happiness and the same pride and the
same emotion because we are honoring a
dear friend who is a towering force in
movie history in addition to being a
great artist is also a fellow country
countryman Federico Fellini
my friend has been honored by the
Academy before with eight Academy Award
nomination for writing and for for
directing he has won the Oscar for Best
Foreign Language Film four times quite
an accomplishment but tonight we honor
him with the continuity of his work and
the totality of his extraordinary
achievements now it is my pleasure to
introduce you an actor with an
international star and well-respected
friend of both Federico and myself
Marcello Mastroianni
thank you
thank you I'm honored to be a part of
this celebration and the career of this
great man for close to 40 years federico
fellini as contribute of vaster and the
impressive gallery of images but real
and fantastic to the vocabulary of the
cinema in addition to that is
responsible for adding a new word to our
language
Fellini s key
ladies and gentlemen Federico Fellini
please sit down
be comfortable if one here is realized
to be a little bit or to feel a bit
uncomfortable Iike Fellini in
appreciation of one of the screens
master storytellers congratulations
can I give you a kiss I would like to
have the voice of Domingo to say it's a
long long things what I can say well I
really did not expect it or perhaps I
did but not by the way but not before
another 25 years anyway is better now I
come from a country and I belong to a
generation from for which America and
movies were almost the same thing
and now to be here with you my dear
Americans make me feel at home I want to
thank all of you to film making me feel
in this way in these circumstances is
easy to be generous and to thank
everybody I would like naturally first
of all to thank all the people that have
worked with me I can not nominate
everyone let me make only one name of an
actress who is also my wife thank you
the others too late and please stop
crying
you